the latest CBS News poll shows Americans
expect long-lasting economic pain nearly
2/3 of people we spoke to believe some
businesses will bounce back fast but
others will not
we also found more Americans disapprove
of president Trump's handling of the
crisis as it wears on Ben Tracy is at
the White House Ben the president is
still pushing for businesses to reopen
as soon as possible good morning he is
and the president says he would prefer
to open up the country all at once with
what he calls a big bang CBS News has
now learned that the president is
considering forming an economic task
force this would focus on how you get
the economy back up and running once the
worst of this pandemic is over but for
right now both parties agree that more
financial relief is needed they just
can't agree on how much the
republican-controlled Senate tried to
pass an additional 250 billion dollars
in small business loans on Thursday but
Democrats want double that amount they
want to include money for food stamp
programs hospitals and state and local
governments now as for the wide spread
nationwide coronavirus testing that you
were talking about with dr. agus
President Trump was asked if that's
needed before the country reopens here's
what he said you want to have it and
we're going to see if we have it do you
need it no is it a nice thing to do yes
we're talking about 325 million people
and that's not going to happen as you
can imagine now the government's own
experts including dr. Anthony Fauci have
said that widespread testing and
monitoring is essential before the
country reopens now the federal
government had planned to end funding
for some of those drive-through test
sites that have been popping up in
states around the country in a reversal
vice president Mike Pence now says the
federal funding will continue for those
sites and it will be up to the states if
they want to take them over themselves
Tony all right Ben thank you very much